so uh there's one thing I want to talk
about when it comes to actually getting
to the festival did you see the news
that actually it's not news we got an
email from a listener who inquired about
the shuttles from Nashville I don't know
if you have it up Barry
um but if you want to read the
highlights of this email which I I knew
like I I had heard Rumblings about them
not doing the shuttles this year for the
first time I had heard that but I hadn't
actually like officially known it for
sure yet uh this guy did the Lord's work
and went and asked um we didn't ask
Bonnaroo because you know people count
on these shuttles so uh he asked and he
got a response from them and uh the
answer was not good
right uh let's see
as of now they are are not doing
shuttles this year
uh big news uh because he's got a bunch
of people who fly in so they're gonna
have to find a way to get from Nashville
deal with all that traffic uh
um gonna cost him a lot of money you
know he's figuring a couple three
hundred dollars uh per person to figure
out how to get there so so this is my
dilemma I hate to make this personal but
if I'm coming in I'm gonna have to be
flying and I would fly into Nashville
and my anticipation was to do one of two
things uh have you guys bring all my
stuff in and just shuttle down and you
know I
walk in and everything is set up for me
um wouldn't that be nice stay with it I
could also stay you know on a bus with
um with some record labels but I don't
want to do that I want to stay with you
guys but the other option was
to rent a car and drive in and just
sleep in that car and you know use some
of the stuff that you guys would bring
up for me and I would just sort of like
supplement it around like a van that I
rented
but the shuttle being that you know that
was available was my first option not
having the shuttle now ensures that I
have to rent a car that's going to cost
me for two days if I do a Saturday night
Sunday night that's going to be 300 400
um my God I I that was a that was a kick
in the gut
yeah makes it complicated it doesn't
inexpensive really expensive
yeah I mean the flight of itself is is
not terrible it was the it was the
rental car that was the whole uh hold up
for me and you know I'm just not you
know in love with the idea of bringing a
rental car to Bonnaroo which it by the
way every year something has happened to
my car
somebody has hit it
somebody is is you know you know I've
flattened a tire uh something has
happened in my car every single year yes
I would love to bring a rental car into
this situation that's what you need make
sure you get that insurance
yeah
yeah I guess you can't fly into
Chattanooga can you
too expensive
it would be much more expensive yeah
okay but even then I'd still have to
rent a car
it's not like I have some extra cars
sitting in there no but there's usually
yeah it's true I need I need Russ to go
through a few more breakups an extra
card too inventory is running low
oh my God if you could start a used car
business and it's just called breakup
cars
he's only cars and breakups yeah they
don't break down they just break up
that's that's why I don't know if you
knew this but that's how big Big Hearted
Smitty got his name down there
his heart was too big yeah in internal
Chattanooga joke for all those who don't
understand new big-hearted yes this
could be the next happy mothers
I was really really bummed with yeah
it's happy for you not for them
um I was really bummed to hear about the
uh the lack of shuttle news I hope
that's something that they readdress uh
in the future it's probably too late now
but boy I really hope that's something
that they uh my choice because they're
right on the cusp of selling out right
you think you've got more people coming
you got more people flying in so
shuttle seem necessary
you almost think some entrepreneur out
there would realize there's an
opportunity
yeah
the insurance risk is out of control
though
for somebody just do it as a one-off
I don't know some company uh yeah I mean
party bus it let's party bus it